Hey, this is sort of weird.
Former Arkansas Governor Mike Huckabee and
former US senator Rick Santorum are hanging
out in Russia and you can join them for five
to $12,000.
This is just the strangest, that also sort
of most classless thing.
The two Republicans were just in St Petersburg
and they've been promoting a cruise.
You can go on a cruise with them.
This is just so bizarre.
It's called the Baltic experience with Governor
Mike Huckabee and guest speaker, Senator Rick
Santorum.
The cruise will stop in St Petersburg, Russia,
Helsinki, Finland, Copenhagen, Denmark, Tallinn,
Estonia, Stockholm, Sweden, and more.
This is for profit tickets are five to $12,000
depending on, I guess, how much time you want
to have with my CocoaVia, Rick Santorum.
Probably
what size room you get and what kind of a
view you get from that room on the big cruise
ship.
How could be promoted this on his Facebook
page as a quote, unforgettable trip to the
Baltics.
He talks about the weather.
Very strange.
How could be also I guess tweeting jokes where
he said enjoyed dinner on the Baltic Sea with
Jane Huckabee and dear friends, Rick and Karen
Santorum.
Note to the media, we are not here to collude
but to see if we can get the uranium back
that Hillary sold.
We told the Vlad we could be more flexible
after the election and then Huckabee own wife
who's just a hilarious woman responding to
the tweet we were colluding.
People are actually talking about Russian
collusion and Russian connections here.
I genuinely don't see it that way.
I see this solely as a cringy money grab unless
you can get me some evidence that this is
anything more than that.
You don't have to speculate what this is all
about.
It's just money.
Yes.
Okay.
Santorum is connected to that Russian agent,
Maria Buthaina and yes, it seems like Betsy
devoss was in Russia at the exact same time
as how it could be in Santorum, but I think
those are just coincidences.
I have no reason to think that this is anything
but a brazen money grab from these two.
What I really want to know is who's willing
to pay 12 grand to go on a boat with Mike
Huckabee and Rick Santorum?
I'm not being sarcastic.
If you know anyone who went on this thing
or is going on this thing up, please get them
in touch with me.
What has gone horribly wrong in your life
that you feel compelled to pay money to go
on a boat to talk to Mike Huckabee and Rick
Santorum and hear them speak?
That's who I want to talk to.
And the only real question mark about this
for Santorum and Huckabee, this is just a
money grab.
And strangely enough, these things are much
more widely available than some people might
imagine.
And some of them are even more cringey than
this one.